-There was stunning news
in the worlds of politics
and media today
when Fox News announced
that they were abruptly
cutting ties
with their top rated host,
Tucker Carlson,
less than a week
after a massive settlement
over the Dominion Voting Systems
defamation lawsuit.
For more on this,
it's time for a closer look.
♪♪
We've been doing this show
for just over nine years.
Eight of those
have been dominated
by the nonstop insanity
of the Trump era.
So I didn't think anything
could shock me anymore.
Then today, this happened.
-Big breaking news in media,
big business story,
big media story,
big political story.
Fox News announcing in the
last hour Tucker Carlson is out
effective immediately.
-Tucker Carlson is out
at Fox News?
Oh, my God, does this mean
Fox News has gone...
[Echoes] woke?
[ Thunder rumbles ]
[ Applause ]
When I heard that news,
I went through all the stages
of Tucker's face in one sitting.
First, I was shocked...
...then I was confused...
...then I did the Tucker laugh.
[ Laughs maniacally ]
That's actually
closer than you think.
-[ Laughs ]
-But then I had
so many questions.
What are we gonna do
without Tucker?
Who else is going to tell us
when M&Ms are [Bleep] anymore,
you know?
You know, would be
really funny, though,
if they replaced him at 8 P.M.
with the new green M&M.
That'd be pretty funny.
The decision was apparently
so sudden
that according to
"The New York Times"...
And the announcement
from Fox was so stunning,
even the network's own anchors
seemed caught off guard
when they read the official
statement on the air today
in what felt like a decree
from state television
in some sort of weird
cult-like dictatorship.
-We have some news
from within our Fox family.
Fox News Media
and Tucker Carlson
have mutually agreed
to part ways.
Tucker's last show
was this past Friday,
and starting tonight,
"Fox News Tonight" will air
live at 8 P.M. Eastern.
It will be an interim show with
rotating Fox News personalities
until a new host is named.
We want to thank Tucker Carlson
for his service
to the network as a host
and, prior to that,
as a long term contributor.
-Wow. I've seen more
convincing reads
on North Korean state TV.
Tucker didn't even get
a farewell show.
Fox really knows
how to disappear someone.
I'm shocked they didn't just go
with this as their statement --
So you heard there Tucker's last
show was Friday, April 21st,
which means -- and this
is totally real --
that what I'm about to show you
is his final segment
as a Fox News anchor.
-We'll be back.
By the way, the entire
episode of "Let Them Eat Bugs,"
not quite as good as pizza,
streaming now on Fox Nation.
Use a promo code "Originals"
for 30 days free.
And we'll be back on Monday.
-No, you won't.
Turns out even that was a lie.
Truly amazing, though,
his last segment on TV
was not a rousing monologue
or a grand farewell,
but a reminder to watch
a special report,
I guess, about eating bugs,
which apparently
is a problem now.
That sounds like
how you get fired.
Rupert Murdoch calls you up
and says,
[ Australian accent ]
"Oi, Tucker, eat bugs,
you [ Bleep ]."
[ Normal voice ] And this is all
such a fitting end for Tucker,
because he was always terrified
that he'd lose his show
after getting canned at to other
cable networks, CNN and MSNBC.
And he was specifically afraid
that Donald Trump
would be the one
to destroy him.
Which is why Tucker spent
so much time spoon-feeding
Trump's bull[Bleep]
to his viewers
despite knowing it
was all bull[Bleep].
After the coup attempt
on January 6th,
Tucker called Trump --
Tucker made the same mistake
everyone else who sucks up
to Trump makes.
He thought he could
harness Trumpism
and use Trump for his own ends
while remaining
completely unscathed.
But ultimately, they all
learned the same lesson.
You can't let a tiger loose
and not get mauled,
even if it's the biggest,
dumbest looking tiger
in the zoo.
Ultimately -- Tiger's
not gonna catch me.
Whoa!
Ultimately, Tucker's
shtick caught up to him.
His whole game was framing
racist, conspiratorial
bull[Bleep]
and in a
"just asking questions"-style,
not taking responsibility
for anything,
but rather posing a bunch
of ludicrous hypotheticals
to scare his audience
like this one.
-Curt Schilling wrote
a social media post
defending Donald Trump.
And in 2021, that's not allowed.
You could lose
your insurance for that.
You could also lose
your bank account, your website,
your access to e-mail
and social media,
your ability to communicate
with the outside world.
And there's nothing
you can do about it,
because you can also
lose your lawyer.
No legal representation
for you.
How long before they cut off
your water and electricity,
before UPS won't deliver
your packages.
And not to wreck your day,
but guess what?
Amazon is now one of America's
biggest grocery providers.
Good thing you
don't need to eat.
-How long before they cut off
your water and electricity,
before UPS won't deliver
your packages?
How long until they cancel
your favorite TV show
and fire your favorite
TV show host?
And what if that TV show host
is a person named
Tucker Carlson?
And what if it turns out
that you are Tucker Carlson
and you realize mid-monologue
that you're talking
about yourself?
What happens to you, then?
Do you go to CNN or MSNBC?
Because if you can't,
because those networks
already fired you,
what if you have
to go to Newsmax
and share a dressing room
with Mike Lindell
and he uses pillows
even though they're filled
with bricks and smell
like urine?
What if Newsmax refuses
to hire you
and Amazon refuses to deliver
packages and grocery stores
refuse to sell you food
in order to survive?
You have no choice but to...
-Eat bugs.
-Now --
[ Laughter ]
As we mentioned --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Tucker's abrupt ouster
comes less than a week
after Fox agreed
to pay a whopping $787 million
in the defamation case
brought by
Dominion Voting Systems
for pushing Trump's
deranged election lies.
And they did that
because they were terrified
of losing Trump's audience.
Now, personally, I would have
loved to see a trial,
mainly because it would
have been so funny
and cathartic to see Fox hosts
like Tucker
or Jeanine Pirro on the stand.
"The election wasn't rigged.
I was just lying for ratings."
"Objection, Your Honor.
The Bible the witness
swore in on
is actually a box of wine with
Bible written on it in Sharpie."
But that would have been
bad for Fox,
and Fox knew that.
Rupert Murdoch himself
would have been forced
to testify.
And based on how
the deposition went,
Murdoch knew that
would not go well.
He pointed a finger
at the lawyer
who had questioned him
for Dominion and said,
"I think he would
strongly disagree with that."
To which the Dominion lawyer
replied,
"Indeed, I do."
Yeah, I would guess
the last thing a Fox employee
wants to see pointing their way
is Rupert Murdoch's finger,
a.k.a. the Reaper's scythe.
That's probably
how Tucker got fired.
Rupert just pointed
a finger at him
and Tucker said,
"I'll get my stuff."
Rupert Murdoch has never used
that bony appendage
for the purposes
of delivering good news.
[ Australian accent ] "Oi, you
there? That's right. You.
You know what
you're about to get?
An edible arrangement
that says, 'Thanks
for all the hard work.'
Did you put the beetles
in the honeydew?
Oh, good, good. Very good.
Eat bugs, you [Bleep]."
[ Normal voice ] So --
[ Laughter ]
So this case exposed
the grimy inner workings
of the right's leading
propaganda network,
like the fact that
they all thought Trump sucked
and thought his cronies
were morons and weirdos.
As you'll recall, one court
filing in the case revealed
that Tucker had said of Trump...
Among other things.
It's so funny to me that Tucker
talks like a divorcée
from a soap opera.
"I'm so glad Aleister died
in that skiing accident.
I hate him passionately."
"Hello, darling, it's me.
I'm back from the dead.
And now I'm...
[Echoes] woke."
[ Thunder rumbles ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
But no matter how much
they hated him privately,
Tucker and his buddies
know they have to keep
Trump's base on their side,
which is why they kept
pretending to buddy up to Trump,
which is why he was so poetic
that one of Tucker's last acts
as a Fox host
was flying down to Florida
to grovel in an interview
with Trump,
where he pretended
to be fascinated
by every word Trump uttered.
Watch Tucker's
facial expressions
in each of these exchanges
with Trump.
-I said, "Abdul,
if you do anything,
you're gonna get
hit really hard."
Literally, I even -- he said,
"But sir, why? Why?"
I wouldn't say it was
a long preparation,
but I did want to talk
about nuclear,
because I consider it to be
the single greatest threat
the world has.
A beautiful female interpreter.
She was very beautiful.
Today, if you say it,
they'll say, "This is terrible.
You're not allowed to say that."
But she was very professional.
She spoke every word for him.
[ Laughter ]
-He looks like a 12 year old
listening to his older brother
talking about touching a female
breast for the first time.
"Yeah, it was over the sweater,
but still it definitely
counted."
[ Laughter ]
"That's so cool.
You're my idol."
You can see it dawning
on Tucker's in real time.
That's the moment
he thought to himself,
"Oh, I'm gonna get fired."
In fact, Tucker's prophecy
that Trump was a destroyer
seems to be coming true,
because as Tucker
loses his job,
Trump is ascendant in the polls
over his likely main rival,
Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis.
DeSantis has been
sinking in the polls,
and instead of getting
tougher in response,
he seems to be
getting more nervous
and looking pretty shaky.
-What will Ron DeSantis do?
He is trailing in the polls,
struggling with endorsements,
and Trump clearly smells blood.
-According to a new
"Wall Street Journal" poll
taken last week, Trump pulled
in 48% of the support
among likely Republican
primary voters.
The next person closest
to him is DeSantis,
who is 24 points behind.
-Governor, polls show
you falling behind Trump.
Any thoughts on that?
-I'm not a candidate.
So we'll see if
and when that changes.
-Holy -- Holy [Bleep],
look at his face.
[ Laughter ]
He's acting like his mom just
found weed in his sock drawer.
"Ronald, is this your marijuana?
That would certainly explain
why you've been eating
pudding with your hands."
Guys, there was a story
about Ron DeSantis
eating pudding with his hands.
And we know it wasn't
a big story,
but we're going to talk
about it a lot on the show
over the next few months.
We'd love if you caught up.
[ Laughter ]
Guy who ate pudding
with his hands
thinks he should be president.
Was just sitting there one day
and was like, "You know,
who would make a good president?
I think I would."
[ Laughter ]
This dude is supposed to be
the great Republican savior.
He's stammering
more than Cousin Greg.
"Uh, I am not, uh,
as of this hereby moment, uh,
a candidate as such.
And, um, we shall see, uh,
if and when,
upon consideration
of various, uh, factors,
if that should change
in any, uh, ch-- forthwith."
It is too bad
we won't get another
Tucker-DeSantis interview.
They could have just made
these faces back and forth
with each other.
Tucker's ouster is obviously
a stunning development
in the world of politics
and media.
But it was yet again another
illustration of the core problem
at the heart of GOP politics.
They all try to suck up to Trump
and harness Trumpism
for profit or political gain,
and in the end,
they all get burned.
In Tucker's case, he debased
himself in service of Trump,
and it didn't work.
All he'll ever be remembered for
is devoting an entire segment
to a piece of candy
of which Tucker said...
-She's very beautiful.
-This has been a closer look.
♪♪